hi guys so today I'm going to be playing
agario with all of you guys for the very
first time I've never played it before
I'm gonna do a live stream and I can
finally get to know some of you that
have come in New we can all just chat
and stuff and they'll be really good so
yeah if I'm like chatting weird stuff
it's because I'm talking through you and
you're asking weird questions hello
hello hello hello hello okay hello uh
p1s tivo oh dear should i really say all
your names hello iris dieren hello
Thomas Villa Flores hello egg drew media
and hello Jocelyn Alvarez and someone
[ __ ] all over themselves lovely
lovely okay let's let's take but I've
never actually played this game before
so hopefully it'll turn out okay you
might need to help me I know I know you
guys need to feed me or something I
think that's the gist of it you need to
feed me things so I'm hoping that you'll
feed me and I'll get right fall so let's
let's play okay so i just use okay i
just use this woohoo I'm pink as well so
this is good this is hey hey hey hey why
is the lizards everywhere oh I got eaten
by cheyenne i suck at this already okay
um please try pronouncing my name oh
bloody i can't i can't read and play at
the same time this is too much no no no
no no no stop I want to try and play
this game I want to try me good so this
is like that fish game does anyone play
that fish game I'm sure you did it's a
very well-known game I'm going around
the dots instead of it okay right
everyone oh can I eat you I mean you
create you come back
okay I'm getting bigger I'm getting
fatter I'm getting fatter and blue this
time that's a nice leap alibi GLA I
prefer to hate greenie can I you please
please oh my god I'm scared what is
happening how I not played this game
before because everyone was playing it
like so long ago jodha pro jodhpur Oh
has to how do you get to can I have to I
want to can I go faster oh I want this
one thing yeah yep biggest dick us Rudy
I don't want you fine it's fine I can do
without you can press space to multiply
what yay oh my gosh this person no don't
mean darn literally my friends I just
kind of what they must be annoyed by now
because I'm just on my phone constantly
because you guys I'm getting all these
lovely comments but I'm just glued to my
phone I can just read them i I've been
reading every single comment and you
guys have been hot sometimes a cookie
someone's cookie that you have been
leaving me because I just I'm just I'm
just gobsmacked it's amazing and press W
oh so cool i have like shooting bits out
oh I don't really know what I should
probably do it towards someone
the biggest dick is becoming a huge okay
uh oh wow look at the slag so good no I
don't know [ __ ] suck so much how old are
you how old you think I am ok everyone
how would you think I am in the comments
go this question it always gets me I got
told I looked 16 the other day not good
i guess it was also because everyone was
drinking at the time and I didn't really
feel like having a drink so I guess they
just saw that I was underage but a woman
I just didn't really like the drinks
that were on offer so you know I'm not
an alcoholic I don't need to drink oh
yeah d emailer 00 21-23 16 20 22 1823 oh
my gosh you guys are around yeah I'm 22
I'm 22 you're around the right the right
thing I am impressed thank you tell me
what your days have eight have we have
how you been I can't speak I'm really
overwhelmed oh my god there's 97 people
watching ah did you know before friday
on my livestreams i was lucky if i got
about 20 people watching at one time not
that I'm dissing that because they were
20 absolutely amazing people but I'm
just a bit mind blown oh my god there's
100 people what was your reaction when
you knew you won the shoutout I put it
in my video last time I kind of i
snapchatted myself cuz i was on the
train that's it okay wait the story the
shoutout story right okay I was on the
train to Cambridge whatever I was just a
do just listening to my music tryna
tryna oh no don't sting me serious get
away get away um I'm not saying oh yeah
i was on the train listen to my music
and then I get this tweet and it says Oh
up cutie pie is out at you and in my
mind out it is like a negative word
right normally it's
someone doesn't like you or something
that says something bad about you so I
started to freak out I was like no cutie
face or something bad about me why what
I don't understand so uh yeah I started
freaking out and I I watched his video
and then I just yeah I just cried I just
on my own on on the seat and I just I
was just pretty much now I didn't have
any words and I just kind of cried and
then I texted all my friends and it was
gibberish and I just said I want a hug
from everybody because I just needed a
hug like everyone cuz i was just pretty
happy and then all of you guys came in
with your lovely selves being like
awesome and lovely and stuff and yeah i
was just really super super happy so
since then nothing has been able to get
me down a bit I've been a very happy
chappy and I'll probably stay that way
for quite a while that's the story hope
you like it I'm gonna eat ya I'm go
ahead yeah come back here tornado if I
see you or hug you I don't care I'll hug
you oh thank you although it might be a
bit scary someone coming out of the blue
and I'm like would probably think you're
trying to mug me or something so just
hug me but then shout I am NOT mugging
you I am hugging you okay Sarah achy
achy you're okay senpai notice you don't
eat me yes he did I'm so good yeah I
just uh you will see in the video now I
just yeah I don't know but also it's not
I mean obviously is it he made it but
like it's also you it's like because you
could have come over here and just been
like well why did he even choose her
this channel is rubbish but instead you
you certainly comments and we're like
your lovely this channel brilliant I
want to be part of your community and
that's just as awesome oh oh I can hate
you I can eat you I think I can eat you
I can eat you all what happened what
just happened how did that happen why
did that happen oh well I'm three
minimis going at the speed of light I
think I'm not supposed to touch those
green things run I can't run I don't
know I don't think so you got wrecked i
got rekt many times i'm terrible at this
game would you consider yourself a
tomboy interesting question i don't know
because i like to I like to take care of
my appearance and things you know I like
I like wearing nice clothes just stuff
like that but then obviously I like I
like games and when I was kid I was
definitely a tomboy when I was a kid me
and my brother switched toys so he had
my mahuva and I had it Hot Wheels good
cool kids oh I'm gon mean afford a
monster stay away I'm on the leader
board don't you dare don't you dare I'm
pretty happy with it so how many of you
are watching a plane know many cuz you
know multitasking about something I
can't really multitask very well I guess
that's another trade eizan although they
say there's a girls thing I think that's
just multi it's just a person thing
right we gotta think about equality here
your dad what to sort of tech do I talk
about well i guess i'm i've been using
the Razoo by a lot lately because i'm
making an interactive video using c++
and openframeworks so kind of led that i
was thinking actually because who the
best because at the moment i am all
Oh what am I talking about yeah what
okay yeah yeah at the moment I'm doing a
lot of different things so I'm like I'm
making the game and doing like some
modeling and animation and stuff and I
am also doing my interactive video and
I'm doing YouTube videos so I'm thinking
maybe instead of boring you and telling
you about it all and some sort of sit
down cozy catch-up style video I could
just bring you along with me because
I've been going to London a lot lately
in and Cambridge to sort out that Rousey
pie event so maybe I could just start
vlogging at all instead of just talking
to you about you I mean because then
it's like you're there with me you
understand what I'm doing and you can
kind of you know do things with me I
think I'd be nice I can't eat any of
these guys they're all going up there
what's happening out there
he's getting too intense I can't speak
yeah 8 cyl okay my computer is running
slow please close other application guys
you're making my computer run slow oh
yeah gone for first place that's that's
not gonna work but thank you I really
like your enthusiasm I just really can't
see it happening I came ninth once that
damn is good to me cheekbones on Zeke on
fleek who's cheapest mine where are you
from / where do you live well I can't
tell you exactly where I live pretty
much in London pretty much kind of on
the outskirts I used to live in central
but it was too expensive so now I live
kind of on the answer outskirts of
London but I originally came from down
by Cornwall and if you don't know what
Cornwall is you need to go it's so
beautiful down there I miss it and swear
by the sea as well don't shoot me
PewDiePie equals bro army what by you I
don't know because I don't know I just I
always saw you guys is just like my
friends
alone but I don't know don't mind me me
pal I don't know honestly if you want to
give yourself a name you can but I don't
ready don't worry have fun for you just
my pounds my little buddies the puma is
creepy everything is creepy it's all
huge I think this is game has been going
on for too long now and people have gone
too good hey it's Leah I think I knew
that girl I think she's my friend Leah
oh she ain't me yag friend oh right to
or ripu said yag friend you're all my AG
friends you're just yeah give my egg
friend I don't know like people have
said um yag men before within that
sounds like you should all be men enough
no people no not all of you on men but
it makes sense cuz obviously you have
men yag minions oh I kind of like that
but then obviously it can't makes you
think you know or whatever they are oh
so what minions is cool it makes some
kind of cute as well and I've already
said how cheesy i am the weirdest part
I've ever been to is in Scotland it's an
Edinburgh don't leave me I'm telling a
story um and now um were you giving that
to me were you giving it to me thank you
oi single man are fine not good tongue
story I'm so glad that I found you
before unified that's one of the best
thing is he did aha and on and on in da
me that's
oh sorry I'm this i care really happy
whenever oh my god I can't believe it
I've been doing YouTube for two years
and it took me two years to get six
thousand subscribers and I just saw that
website mental so good and then I don't
know how many have we got now I think
there's 17,000 view huh it's amazing
it's so scary as well but is it yeah
it's really amazing I think okay guys
that's what i'm gonna do i'm just gonna
hide here gimme an 800 watts we're gonna
hide back in the air again hi in tank
shakes we can do this heidi i just 800
bucks 800-foot no don't lag on me aight
104 this is working I'm happy I'm happy
he under full stop shooting at me I
can't do this too many people here I'm
really scared no
hey I hid under the green thing I'm
gonna get some pie now what kind of pie
the dessert pie or is it dinner pie i
love banoffee pie we interrupt this
video to remind you to follow yog man on
all social medias to ensure never to
miss such important live streams again
thank you good night everyone you're
awesome have a have a lovely sleep and
stuff and I will see you in my next
video have you ever do even by so
something happened I think you all know
by now PewDiePie freakin mentioned the
channel didn't he at like hmm PewDiePie
had a little shout-out competition thing
a while back no it's just like what
wouldn't it be cool